-Welcome back!
-Thank you for having me.
-This is your sixth time
on the show.
-I know!
I don't know, I keep showing up,
and I show up at 1:00 a.m.
for you.
-1:00 a.m.
-Yeah.
-And I want
to be honest about something.
Really, it makes me feel warm
about the fact
that you're here live.
You are also gonna be on the
"Today" show tomorrow morning.
-7:00 a.m.! Yes.
-7:00 a.m.
-I wonder if people will watch.
Yes, we can do it together.
-I mean, I want to say
to everybody who's up now
to watch the "Today" show
to see how you feel,
but they're not gonna be awake.
-No, no, no, no, no.
I don't know
what's gonna happen.
Like, a little party
in the hotel room or something,
one of those things where
you just stay up all night.
-You got to.
There's no window of time
from 1:00 a.m. to 7:00 to sleep.
-I know.
This is pretty insane.
-Yeah, this is insane.
It's great to have you here.
-Yeah, thank you for having me.
-You have this new film.
-Yes.
-Oh, before --
I want to ask about something
before your new film.
-Always.
Ask me anything.
-You have a dog.
-Yes.
-Tank?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so your dog's Tank.
Last time you were here,
you played a video,
and I want to play it again.
You believe
that Tank can speak English.
-I certainly do.
-And now what -- what does
he say again in this video?
-She.
-She. Gotcha.
I mean, not that gender --
We're gender fluid
in our household, but...
But what does she say again?
-Yeah.
"I love you."
-She said, "I love you".
-Yeah.
-And you have video to prove it.
-Oh, yeah.
-So, everybody, see if you can
hear Tank saying "I love you."
[ Dog growling ]
-I love you.
I love you.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean...
-It's pretty good.
-Now you said that you
promised me that you would bring
more video the next time
of Tank saying other things.
How's that gone?
-It didn't happen.
-It didn't happen?
-There's no story.
There's no nothing.
I have nothing.
-Tank hit a wall.
I've exploited my child enough.
-Maybe, though, I mean,
there is a chance --
-Tank can't do anything else.
Honestly, I don't know.
She may be a one-hit wonder.
-Or maybe the only English
she needed to say
was how much she loved you.
-Aww.
-And after that -- yeah.
-I think there's something
to that.
-Or she's just dumb.
[ Laughter ]
-A little bit of both.
I think she just needed
to express her love.
"I can move on."
-Yeah, "I can move on."
-"I'm done
with this human plane."
-Yes.
-"I'll go back to being a dog."
-"And then I'm gonna go back
to being a dog."
It's very exciting.
You are in this film
that's very different
from "Orange is the New Black."
-It's very different.
Very different.
-A horror film.
-It's a real scary horror movie.
-It's a real scary one.
-I'm not really into --
I appreciate horror movies,
but I've seen three.
I saw "Rosemary's Baby"...
-Classic.
-..."The Exorcist"...
-Another classic, yeah.
-..."Silence of the Lambs."
-So you've seen
the three best ones made.
-Yes, exactly.
So I didn't really --
I don't really know
what's going on.
But I understand that people
like to get scared.
-Yeah.
You really got to the --
-Yes.
-You got to the crux of it.
-I got to the nexus
of the whole operation.
-They like to be scared.
-Yes.
-This is a scary one?
-This is so scary.
I just came from a screening.
-Gotcha.
-'Cause I just wanted to stay up
for the next three days
talking about this movie.
-Yeah.
-And it was -- it's terrifying.
-And you play a mother, right?
-I do.
I play a mother whose child is,
you know --
-How would you
describe the child?
-Not well.
[ Laughter ]
-I will say that -- yeah.
If I, in a trailer,
saw someone say,
"Your child is not well,"
I would want to see.
We're gonna show a clip,
and then let the audience,
much like we let them
judge Tank...
-Great.
-...we'll let them see
if they think he's well or not.
-Thank you.
-Here's a clip from the film.
♪♪♪♪
-[ Humming ]
[ Gasps, panting ]
-What is it?
What happened?
-There's someone in here.
-Where?
-He -- He's in here.
-Honey, it sounds like
you were having a bad dream.
There's no one here.
-No, no, no.
He's in -- He's in here.
He's inside here.
-Oh!
-Well, not well.
Well, not well.
-Yeah.
-Not well.
-Not well, yeah.
-He's got something in his head.
-He's got, like,
an ear worm or something.
[ Laughter ]
-You filmed it in Toronto.
-I love Toronto so much.
-Genuinely?
-Yeah, truly.
Canadians are wonderful people.
-They are.
-At least the people that I met.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's awesome.
-Yeah.
-Canadians in the house.
-They can stay up late
'cause it's only like 10:00
in Canada right now.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, I loved it.
I really loved it.
It was sweet, generous.
It was so cold, though.
-Oh, when did you do it?
-Tank would not pee outside,
actually.
-Really?
-She wouldn't go for walks.
-So, what would you do?
-It was a nightmare.
It was nightmare!
She just -- She paid on
the carpet of the Airbnb.
-Wait.
Did you not get pee pads?
-I did.
But she wouldn't use them.
She was having transitional --
She was, like, having
transitional anxiety, sort of.
-Like, you mean transitioning
into being a Canadian dog?
-Yeah, and just being
in an apartment.
She was up high above,
and it was very cold.
-Gotcha.
-Anyway, it was a great city.
I really liked it.
-Got it.
And were there any times
where you were walking
in the streets of Toronto
and you saw something
that was so typically Canadian?
-Yes.
Yes, Seth.
I was walking down the street,
and I saw a poster of Drake
canoodling with a moose.
And I thought,
"What could be more Canadian?"
-Yeah.
-I thought, "I love Canada."
-"These are my people."
-Yeah.
-If I wanted an emblem
for myself, it'd be --
I mean, that's great.
-I mean,
the maple leaf is great,
but I think this would make
as good if not a better flag
for our neighbors to the north.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was the greatest find
of my time in Toronto.
-That's a fantastic --
They genuinely both seem so
happy to be with one another.
-So happy, so in love.
At peace.
They found some serenity.
- I bet --
-They feel like they're
creatively expressing
themselves.
They're in love.
They're in nature.
They've got it figured out.
-I don't want to speak
for that moose, but I'm guessing
that he would say, "I wuv you!"
[ Laughter ]
-Pretty funny.
-"Drake, I wuv you!"
-[ Groaning ]
-"I love you,
but I'm gonna pee inside."
[ Laughter ]